bonjour catherine conconne bonjour mon
sixième tome on jouera tous les
auditeurs candidates parmi 11 pour les
prochaines élections sénatoriales vous
êtes l'une des deux femmes en lice avec
edith tv laâyoune dont des républicains
catherine conconne avant que le ppm
votre parti avant qu ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle nay jusqu'au bout de
son processus de désignation il semblait
évident que pm n aurait guère eu de
difficultés pour remporter les deux
sièges de sénateurs de la martinique
vous sentez vous ce matin dans la peau
d'une favorite quand je vais aux
élections j'avais beau gagner quand je
vais aux élections je vais pour
convaincre et je ne profite de cette
période pour m en tout cas toute ma
conviction au service d'une cause les
observateurs se sont dits la première
femme sénatrice de martinique sera
catherine conconne c'est bien il faut
surtout pas se fier à ce genre de
prédictions il faut travailler jusqu'au
bout les acteurs parce que ses
observateurs se sont tout simplement
pencher sur la physionomie de des grands
électeurs
peut-être mais comme dirait ma grand
mère handed en ligne fait loin
donc il faut continuer de convaincre les
gens de convaincre que vous vous serez
la meilleure sénatrice que vous avez des
atouts importants pour en tout cas être
la voix de nos collectivités sont nous
associons catherine conconne ma
conviction mon courage mon audace est
également tout cet actif que je porte du
travail que j'ai pu fournir depuis dix
huit ans que je suis dans la violence
oui les coups que vous avez su prendre
vous savez il appela la vie publique
exige des coûts on va là et lorsqu on
mouille son maillot c'est un peu comme
comme au football les joueurs les plus
actifs sur le terrain sont généralement
les plus critiques et catherine conconne
vaut pour le ppm et maurice antiste
notre candidat de votre coalition vous
devez quand même composer avec avec
l'affront de celle d'yvon pakit qui a
refusé les règles de la désignation
après avoir perdu vous lui en vouloir
ils vont pas quitte chaque chaque
personnage a sa façon d'être sa façon de
faire moi je joue collectif je suis
membre de parti gens respectent les
règles lui et si les règles ne me
plaisent pas je démissionne et je quitte
ce parti qui se tenait ce jour ou
l'autre et c'est ce dont je continue je
vous je parle de moi si je continue
d'être membre de ce parti ce que j'en ai
j'en accepte les vrais
et lorsque ces règles on puisse ont été
transparents correctement meunier et
bien il n'y a pas lieu a en tout cas
venir critiquer le parti vous avez
discuté avec lui ou pas du tout il ya
aussi un tannage jeanne rose et il y
également maurice bonté qui aurait dû
être là ce matin mais qui a désisté au
dernier moment le pmm ne sait pas
contrôler ses troupes
vous savez au pmn c'est comme dans une
famille pmn ce que je retiens de pmn
c'est une très belle alliance qui a
fourni un travail considérable à la
martinique pendant que cette ce
regroupement dit lui était aux affaires
au conseil régional
nous n'avons peut-être pas été compris
en décembre 2015
ça nous permet de nous remettre sur le
métier et d'améliorer à la fois de
communication notre façon notre relation
avec les autres mais moi ce que je
retiens de pme ce sont des femmes des
hommes extrêmement déterminé rigou est
au travail et qui sont en capacité avec
leur énergie de fournir un travail
considérable même le reste ce sont des
soubresauts familiaux ce sont des
difficultés que l'on vit partout je
crois que nous sommes pas les seuls et
dont l'histoire retiendra en particulier
le bel actif des pme cette
multiplication des candidatures dans
votre famille politique saveur quand
même conduire un émiettement des votes
qui va en pâtir
vous ou maurice antiste les lecteurs
décidera pour la campagne comme
l'ensemble des candidats vous rencontrer
tous les grands électeurs c'est très
sport à leur rythme s'est très soutenu
ces derniers jours
comment être sûr que le message que vous
vous portez catherine concrètement être
sûr que ce message ses mouches
il faut d'abord à être conviés que soi
même savoir pourquoi on va donner dans
ces élections là quelles sont les
motivations et puis faire de son mieux
pour convaincre les personnes qui sont
devant vous vous savez j'ai beaucoup
fréquenté les mairies de martinique
j'étais à la tête du plan de relance
lorsque nous étions à la région pendant
cinq ans j'ai eu ce dialogue très
interactif très très cool j'ai envie de
dire avec tout les éditer de montigny je
me dis place et souvent remaniant ici
plan de financement retouchant ici un
chantier vous sortir les 250 chantier
que nous avions initiée et qui était
quand même porteur il ce sera suffisant
350 millions de travaux dans le btp à la
santini dont jean-marie beney ce jeu
original on lave non les gens ont
l'habitude de me voir vous savez je n'ai
pas attendu d'être candidate aux
sénatoriales pour répondre aux
invitations des élus dans les communes
d'être présente depuis 17 ans aux fêtes
patronales à toutes les invitations les
manifestations culturelles pour
lesquelles j'étais sollicité j'ai ce jeu
cette relation avec l'amanti simple
sauveur
non j'aime j'aime mon pays j'aime mon
pays pour moi mon pays ce n'est pas de
côté fort de france et puis les autres
qui sont très loin
j'ai l'habitude de dire que pièce côté
pas loin menti ni et j'ai l'habitude de
fréquenter les gens vous savez dans la
plupart des conseils municipaux je me
rends j'ai des amitiés dans le conseil
je connais les méens j'embrasse sinon la
totalité voire la moitié du conseil
le chuv le mal qu il est même chez les
adversaires politiques vous savez
lorsque nous avons été à la région nous
avons eu cette caractéristique de
travailler avec tous les élus de matinée
serge letchimy ne savait pas si ce
message
quand un élu est élu c'est la volonté du
peuple
le respecte et travailler avec lui c'est
respecter la volonté du peuple
donc nous avons travaillé avec tout le
monde dans une ambiance extrêmement
cordial et respectueuse je crois que ça
laisse des traces
le sénat c'est la chambre où on parle
davantage des collectivités vous
reparler de votre fierté d'être
martiniquaise de votre envie de
travailler pour 1 pour lille
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire là-bas
concernant notre martinique
mais j'estime que le sénat et en
particulier pour nos pays je parle
essentiellement de la martinique je suis
profondément martiniquaise le sénat doit
être le rempart de nos collectivités
locales vous savez la matinée qu'à une
histoire qui jeunes qui a moins de 170
ans
depuis cette époque les collectivités en
particulier les mairies ont toujours été
le rempart de la population lorsque
quelque chose ne va pas le premier
réflexe est le maire le maire a embauché
le maire à soulager la souffrance
sociale d'un pays difficile de payer à
l'histoire tourmentée qui devient à ce
moment là le rempart de nos
collectivités locales et bien jusqu'à la
voix des collectivités locales ce
qu'elle ait idir et les ornements par
exemple que vous avez tort de réduire
l'argent octroyé à ces collectivités
d'abord dans une posture je suis pas
celle qui quémandent est qui
exige que la martinique est un regard
exceptionnel j'exigerai que nos pays ne
soient pas traités de la même manière
que département qui a des millénaires
d'existence qui a une continuité
territoriale y compris européennes
extraordinaire
nous sommes un pays particulier nous
sommes pays singulier nous n'avons rien
à voir avec la boîte anne paris
marseille ou les autres nous devons en
tous cas être regardé de manière
différente être regardés avec notre
vision de loire attendons veut pas
l'entendre il faudra que par il entonne
parce que le cheminement que nous avons
choisi de faire avec la france doit être
cheminement respectueux qui respecte
notre dignité notre particularité depuis
jeunes nous acceptons de faire ce
cheminement la main dans la même il faut
pas que notre main soit boyer par une
superpuissance qui nous regardent de nec
avec lequel il ne devrait pas ça change
votre regard sur ce que vous vous
pourriez faire à la chambre haute ce qui
vient de se passer à saint martin
comment tout a été fait n'importe
comment dans ce dans cette île du nord
et on se dit que ça peut arriver
également en martinique
bien sûr vous voyez bien que nous devons
être respectée dans nos singularités
mais nous devons aussi avoir les moyens
de nous organiser nous-mêmes
je suis une adepte de la responsabilité
ce qui s'est passé à saint quentin s'est
peut-être laissé aller y compris
peut-être par le gouvernement mais y
compris en associant ce raid marie-jo
une insouciance nes ou science une
insouciance collective parce qu'il ya
longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu de cyclones
et c'est donc on laisse les anglais
seront 18 ans minimum et cetera non pas
du tout je ne peux pas parler contre
comme les élus du mime
je ne suis pas une populiste donc
j'aimerais que que l'on puisse regarder
nos pays autrement que l'on puisse le
considérer autrement et que lorsqu'à la
martinique on veut appliquer un certain
nombre de mesures qui soient destinés à
nos pays et b que ces mesures soient
adaptés à la singularité à l'exclusivité
que nous représentons et je serai cette
voie je suis aussi la voix de sénateurs
qui prend des initiatives parce que
j'estime qu'il ne suffit pas simplement
d'aller au sénat de voter des lois de
participer à des commissions le pouvoir
que vous donne cette chambre haute pour
l'envoyer par exemple les deux îles deux
sénateurs sortants il faut aussi porter
des initiatives ils l'ont fait
il faut porter des initiatives il faut
en tout cas profiter de ce pouvoir entre
guillemets qui nous est donnée pour
faire ce qu'il ya lieu de faire de mieux
pour le pays et je serai celle qui ira
frapper aux portes qui va enfoncer les
portes même quand il faudra parce que
nous avons dû rejoindre catherine nous
avons besoin la chronologie à google de
catherine conconne ne risque pas de
faire de faire un mauvais ménage avec
cette image qu'on a de la chambre haute
une femme une femme du siam saurez vous
serez vous être sage que google qu'est
ce que vous appelez de sagement dormir
dans un fauteuil non ce ne sera pas
c'est pas du tout ma nature je serai
celle qui exigera jusqu'à celle qui sera
déterminée courageuse et audacieuse de
maths
quitte à me faire traiter de grandes
gueules mais si cette grande gueule
profite à mon pays profite à son
émancipation et bien en tout cas cette
grande gueule va servir la cause de la
cause du pays
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos
catherine conconne l'une des onze
candidats en lice pour les élections
sénatoriales bonne journée
[Musique]